from a Breaking Bad movie to a brand-new
Stephen King adaptation there are some
great new Netflix originals landing on
the streaming service next month let's
take a look at everything good coming to
Netflix on October two thousand nineteen
nobody needs a reminder of the Stephen
King revival that's happening right now
but fewer people are aware that king's
son who rights under the name Joe Hill
is also becoming a name to know in the
horror world Hill's 2007 novel horns was
adapted into a film starring Daniel
Radcliffe in 2014 and his third novel
Nosferatu was recently adapted into a
series on AMC that looks downright
terrifying so what kind of epic premise
could they concoct when they work on a
story together in the tall grass is one
of those premises that only a king could
come up with and only a king could pull
off the film like the story follows a
pregnant woman and her brother who enter
a field of deadly grass after they hear
a child crying for help what follows
next is the kind of terror that takes
root and doesn't let go you can get your
chlorophyll when in the tall grass hits
Netflix on October 4th
for two seasons now big mouth has proven
itself to be one of the raunchiest
animated shows available following the
adventures of a bunch of school-aged
children as they go through puberty but
underneath the crude humor and poop
jokes you'll find a lot of heart in this
show creators Nick Kroll Andrew goldberg
jennifer flack it and Mark Levin are
returning next month with a brand new
season which you'll be able to stream on
October 4th
as far as series finales go Breaking Bad
wrapped up its final season with a bow
tying together nearly every dangling
plot bread and a breathtaking final few
episodes and closing out on Walter White
himself sprawled dead in a meth lab so
what's left to tell why would creator
Vince Gilligan return six years later to
rip off that bow one word Jesse the last
we saw of Jesse he was driving off into
the night cackling like a lunatic
finally freed from those crazy white
supremacists where does he go from there
remember this is a guy who recently
found out that his partner watched one
of his girlfriend's overdose and did
nothing to stop it then he watched
someone execute his other girlfriend
leaving behind a young boy for whom he
cares deeply he's going to be carrying a
lot of emotions in this new Audi
strapped in when El Camino a breaking
bad movie roars onto Netflix on October
11
the horror continues later this October
with fractured a tense psychological
thriller featuring Sam Worthington and
Lily rave Worthington stars as a loving
father who goes on the hunt for his
daughter and wife after they vanished
from a hospital emergency room the more
he searches the more he begins to
suspect that the hospital itself may
have something to do with the chilling
disappearances from the sounds of it
fractured is going to be chalked full of
fun guns and Sam Worthington and you can
experience the wild ride on October 11
it's the month for all things horror so
it stands the reason that Netflix would
be doubling down on its scares if you
missed the first season of haunted when
it dropped in 2018 here's the basic
premise people who have had real
paranormal encounters meet the show's
producers and discuss their experiences
while reenactments play out along with
their stories look for Haunted season 2
to scare the living daylights out of you
on October 11 there's a ton of talent
packed into the laundromat a
biographical film about a shady law firm
located in Panama that spent years
helping some of the world's richest
people launder their money Academy Award
winners Meryl Streep and Gary Oldman
share screen time with Antonio Banderas
in this off-the-wall comedy directed by
Steven Soderbergh after her husband
drowns elderly Ellen Martin played by
Streep finds herself inadvertently on
the trail of a widespread insurance
fraud scheme forget about all that real
laundry you promised yourself you do and
take a look at the laundromat when it
opens on October 18 it's a fact Paul
Rudd makes everything better
from ant-man the celery man Rudd brings
death charm and humor to nearly every
character he touches this guy would
never hurt a fly
you're welcome in fact the only thing
better than one Rudd is two rods which
is why you should definitely watch
living with yourself and living with
yourself
Paul Rudd pulls double duty as a
corporate loser just trying to get
through the day-to-day grind and is a
better funnier smarter version of
himself that emerges after he undergoes
a mysterious spa treatment the official
trailer teases a show that looks both
hilarious and surprisingly creepy look
for it on October 18 what would you do
if you were one of the last survivors of
the apocalypse as Netflix sees it you'd
either blindfold yourself keep really
quiet
team up with some local high school
gangs take a road trip with your
father-in-law get out of the rain or
just cry a lot but what's to say you
couldn't enjoy that apocalypse in
daybreak a nuclear explosion near the
town of Glendale turns the area into a
wasteland but that won't stop one team
from living life to the fullest the
trailer promises a ferris bueller style
fourth wall breaking rock up to and
including Bueller himself Matthew
Broderick take a look when daybreak
arrives on Netflix on October 24th
back in the 70s comedian Rudy ray Moore
created a fictional persona that he
named Dolomites
he went on to make a series of
exploitation films based around that
character and went down in history who
better to play this loud talking
swaggering cinematic hero than Eddie
Murphy who steps into the role of more
with what critics are calling feisty
Glee Wesley Snipes and keegan-michael
key co-star and if you're looking for an
absolutely wild movie night this October
you can stream Dolomites is my name on
the 25th as we wind down the Netflix
originals we have to give a shout out to
some of the new stand-up comedy's
hitting small screens next month on the
first you'll get front-row seats - Nikki
Glaser bangin and irreverent stand-up
that sees the comic covering everything
from sex to careers on the 8th look for
Deon Cole to take the stage with cold
hearted followed by Jenny slate stage
brides on the 22nd finally the month
will end on a high note with a brand new
set from Arsenio Hall smart and classy
on October 29 that does it for all the
fantastic new Netflix originals to look
for in October now let's see what other
movies will be worth stayed up for
Netflix is upcoming action films are as
diverse as they are explosive October
first sees the glutes of the new
arrivals with both Charlie's Angels
films men in black to the island and
Troy hitting the service all at once
you can also rewatch both bad boys films
an anticipation of 2020s bad boys for
life which reunites Will Smith and
Martin Lawrence as the iconic buddy-cop
duo after that you'll be able to catch
the first men in black on October 19 as
well as master Z the if man legacy on
the 23rd that's a sweet lineup eager
what on earth was that it wouldn't be
October without some new scares and
Netflix is stepping up to the plate the
first of the month marks the arrival of
1997's horror satire screen 2 as well as
2016
sinister circle you should also keep an
eye out for am i an indie screamer about
an artificial intelligence in a girl's
phone that convinces her to start taking
lives like the action genre most of the
monster amma additions land at the
opening of the month you'll start seeing
some all-time greats in your browsing
options including blow crash Sin City
the bucket list and Trainspotting we're
also getting oceans 12 and 13 no
reservations and the Will Smith
tearjerker The Pursuit of Happyness
later in the month
don't miss dark crime starring Jim
Carrey weigh against type is a
hard-boiled detective on the hunt for a
cold-blooded murderer and on the 31st
you can't miss Martin Scorsese's classic
Raging Bull check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]